hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben freunde es wurde sich wirklich
zahlreich in den kommentaren gewünscht
von daher darf ich euch heute herzlich
willkommen heißen zu einer episode molas
mit luca mitglieder befinden sich in
einer raumstation mitten im weltall und
einer zwei- oder allerhöchstens drei
dieser zehn spieler sind nicht das was
sie zu sein scheinen
denn sie sind mörder ok impostors also
schwindler die grundlegende aufgabe der
impostors ist es die crew mitglieder zu
töten und immer wenn eine person getötet
wurde und dieser tote körper dann
reportet wurde hat die gruppe zeit zu
diskutieren mittelstädt et cetera und zu
sagen hey ich habe das gesehen das war
der blaue ist der mörder dann sagt
blauen jülich nicht ich war in dem raum
und habe das und das gemacht und dann
ist auf einmal lieder der mörder muss
man abstimmen
und derjenige der die meisten stimmen
bekommt fliegt aus dem schiff staub ist
relativ verständlich und wir fangen
einfach mal an das hier denn übrigens
ich mysteriös
[Musik]
ja
ich bin teil der crew
jemand wird getötet sondern wir jetzt
zeit zu diskutieren
hier schreiben die alle auf
italienischen sammlung germany la stanza
essen spaß wenn wir das dann mit seinem
freund gespielt aber
merkel selber wenn ich meine face käme
allerdings mal kurz ausblende seht ihr
oben links schon einige aufgaben die
erledigt werden müssen denn die aufgabe
von den crewmitgliedern ist es nicht nur
heraus wenn jetzt ist das licht
ausgefallen
super die aufgabe von uns crew
mitgliedern ist es nicht nur die
impostors ausfindig zu machen und zu
überleben sondern wir müssen auch die
tas kompletten und tasks beispielsweise
[Musik]
das ist beispielsweise
drei wochen später hier
das ist eine task also kleine mini games
ich muss jetzt das beispielsweise
hiermit verbinden das gerne dass hiermit
und das irgendwie hiermit und dann jetzt
ist der balken bisschen weiter nach oben
gegangen
der schwarze steht da oben rechts in der
ecke ich weiß nicht ob bei der gerade
eine aufgabe macht oder ob er nur so tut
und ein im post da ist
ich würde sagen wir bewegen uns mal ganz
langsam zu ihnen tut mich okay da sind
jetzt zwei spielt als in der 3 ich
dachte ich wurde getötet aber grün wird
getötet schreiben alle purple war das
von daher vertraue ich den jetzt einfach
mal und wollte auf morgen purple
schreibt hier ein think that bruder
ich war ja so block
[Musik]
wels
na gut dann lief setzt halt nicht so gut
man tötet ihr mich nicht
[Musik]
ich bin mörder leute zeige ich euch
meine fitness schwer gespielt wird also
werden jetzt unten die buttons kill
sabotage und report also wir können auch
selber eine leiche quasi reporten den
tisch das 9
da sind zum glück sind das die andere
leute also ich dachte erst da hätte
jemand gesehen aber das waren zum glück
andere mitspieler also andere mörder
andere im post da und ich muss jetzt
sechs und 35 sekunden warten bis ich
wieder jemand umbringen kann so ich habe
jetzt selber die leiche reporte die mein
kumpel also ein anderer ein postler
umgebracht hat damit die person neben
mir sie papa
der ist es nicht normal denn immer noch
drin leute ich bin noch im rennen so
sich 44 sekunden warten bis ich wieder
jemanden töten kann von der tu ich jetzt
in der zeit einfach so als würde ich ein
paar quests machen
ich stelle mich hierhin und tue so als
ob ich was tun würde
kann ich am besten wenn man ja auch mal
so
das ging jetzt schnell
und wenn direkt als erstes getötet ok
blau wurde getötet meine lieben freunde
das heißt ich sage ein us- kill him wie
nie
vielleicht war es gar nicht so schlau
dann blöd gelaufen naoto kan ich klicke
mal direkt auf sabotage und lass die
elektrizität ausfall
hallo es geht gar nix allerdings bin ich
jetzt wieder mörder meiner lieben
freunde von daher muss ich leute
umbringen
wer macht denn jetzt schon ein emergency
meeting
[Musik]
ja da ist er erst aus meinem team schon
rausgeflogen
und wir haben gewonnen warum er hat mich
einfach beim start mitten in der
cafeteria getötet
und jetzt haben wir wieder bin ich so
ein crew made
ja bei euch so ein trittbrett
ich war die ganze
das gar nicht gewesen sein
niemand
jan blau rot offen
ich hätte gern rot runter fliegen sehen
ja haben wir irgendwo dann auch quests
für mich erzählt tod habe er gesagt dass
roten keinem keinen im post tower ist
jetzt habe ich mich natürlich ein
bisschen verdribbelt ich habe gesagt
dass es rot ist rothe schon tot oder
gelb und gelb ist auch tot also ja sieht
nicht gut aus ich werde jetzt einfach
komplett verwirren kinder kuchen
ja
die jemals schon mal mörder gesehen der
kinder kuchen gesagt hat ich glaube
nicht warum fliegt das ding da einfach
um
und alles andere steht auf dem boden in
dieser raumstation physikalisch gesehen
macht was
da bin ich
lappen pinky wie geht's dir denn schon
mal ganz tief in die augen
ja wenn pinky mörder werden hatte mich
schon selbst getötet ich laufe jetzt
einfach zusammen mit pinkel hier ein
bisschen robert petit eigentlichen hut
warum ich hab gar nicht so einfach eine
glatze pizza gleiches essen da jemand
sein glas verschüttet leute nur wenige
minuten später ich vertrau stefan
stephan ich habe dir vertraut ich werde
die post da jetzt so fertigmachen
ich kann das richtig gut irgendwie ist
heute auch mal die die die besten
anderen raum hab auch mal an der stelle
mich dass heute wieder zeit nicht
arbeiten wenn die freunde wenn euch am
morgen erst mit luca gefallen hat das
könne einen daumen hoch und dem video
ihr da schreibt man in die kommentare
darauf hätte dass ich das event noch mal
zusammen mit freunden spiele müsste ich
mir nur freunde kaufen das ein bisschen
stressig aber was ich unbedingt noch
sagen wollte